[Applause]
well actually we were just chatting uh
right now about something you say you're
very superstitious especially as a
performer yeah i am too how how
seriously superstitious are you i'm i
mean i it's really not like a novelty
it's really dead serious to me i i live
i'm ruled by many of them
like i have to fix them if i if i do
something that in some ways might
say defy the superstition i have to find
means of fixing it it's all very
complicated and time consuming it's
probably incredibly boring
no it depends on what silence no it
depends on i think they're more scared
than anything
you think i'm gonna put the mojo on my
god she's got eerie powers what are we
talking about here like what kinds of
things do you do um well there's certain
things because i'm i
you know i worked a lot in the theater
as a young person so i'm really there's
a lot of superstitions about things you
can and cannot do in in the theater in
dressing rooms things you cannot words
you cannot say you can't whistle in a
dressing room you can't say certain
words in a dressing room and just to
make matters more complicated what
happens is if i have a good show and
i've done certain things before that
show then they have to become part of a
routine so that means that eventually
i'm getting to the theater like three
hours early to incorporate all these
weird
things into my thing you gotta get hit
in the head by the bucket i swear i've
gotta eat a cat
but you know you can't light for
instance um those of you who are smokers
and sinners like someone i know um
can't light a cigarette from a candle
never light anything off a candle you
know you have to say something the first
of every month be when i fly which is a
nightmare i gotta do all this stuff
before i fly oh you're a bad thing like
you're like what do you have to do when
you fly because that's something a lot
of people how do i tell you because that
would hurt the let's just say it's a
physical task
okay actually i have to pick up the
plane and carry it myself
and then you're okay and then i'm fine
are you a wreck on the plane are you
like running through all these weird
rituals on the plane and freaking
everyone out well i try to keep them to
myself because i think that's only fair
you know i don't want to you know
burden everyone else on the airplane but
my friend actually i'll tell his he has
a thing where he has to um do he has to
tap the plane before he gets on the
airplane and i actually have to do
something like that too but if he
doesn't do it see i'll just get off the
airplane and do it and
they let you do they let you go out and
like touch the plane oh yeah don't let
me
i'm a frequent flyer oh all right all
right
he has to if he's not tapped the plane
he has to tap in his head secretly
everybody on the plane so he has got it
he's got to make it small so he's
sitting in his seat like this
oh makes me feel concretely normal yeah
does he get escorted off the plane a lot
i would like i don't know him
i would hope no is this part of the
ritual to make that thing keep falling
off
you know it's just bad you know i've got
a lot of work to do this week conan and
frankly i can't be concerned with my
clothing you're right you're right i got
more important things on my brain you
gotta go that's right that's fair that's
right someone was saying i was actually
uh before the show that you were saying
you're very frugal right now now is this
frugal are you cheap are you cheap is
that what you're talking one might call
it cheap i call it frugal
it has more it sounds more poetic or
something yeah it's very pretty it has a
very nice sound to it yeah like what i
mean do you uh give people salted nuts
for christmas and stuff
that's such a good idea
do it then all right
no you know it's you know it's legal say
hey come on that's a dollar 39.
it's more than you got last year mom not
kidding
oh wow
poor mom
i'm so kidding
no what are you talking about such a
good idea i have to get a notepad right
now
that's what i do no one no you know i
take the subway at all times so i can
save money except when it's dangerous
you know
you take the subway that's commendable
yeah you know post-its i don't use i use
them a lot and then i use the other side
and rip off the sticky and use that side
okay that's that's crazy actually i
think post-its are really cheap you know
i can't think of one like really frugal
moment now of course but i just know
that i am just trust that i am i guess i
have just no wacky anecdotes about no no
but are you going to be like stealing
fruit from our green room no but i will
be in my in my dressing room upstairs at
saturday night live that i'm hosting
this weekend with rem
um
i will be very nicely done
very nicely done
there's a really great there's a great
nbc notepad
oh that's so sad i'm sure they'd give it
to you if you asked and you're like
really it's my not being frugal i just
like it oh that's fine but you know what
i was up front i told sue leibman who's
the talent person up there i said i'm
gonna take it i just was upfront and
forthright about it and then of course
like oh no take it but if they find out
you stole them all those bells go off
when you walk out they're like
they have a big tag on it she's got the
pad
all the clothes i wear on this show have
that big tag that sets off an alarm
right you can see it during the
monologue a big thing hanging off my ass
it's embarrassing
well i gotta
i gotta make sure i mention as you just
did
they saw it uh
that you are hosting starting out live
uh this week with uh rem that's great
are you nervous
[Applause]
thinks he can take all our guests
you're coming out with me
completely out of his mind
you know that's now gonna become one of
the superstitions you know she's right
she had a good talk show appearance and
now she has to be stolen by a crazy
crazy man at the end one of ours too
hey there you go
factory of the law